-Welcome back
to "The Tonight Show."
We're hanging out
with one of my favorites,
Kate McKinnon right here.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Now we are about --
We're about to play a game
called "Hey Robot."
Here we go.
♪ Hey, hey ♪
♪ Hey, robot ♪
-Now here's how it works.
This is based
on the real board game,
Hey Robot,
that you can play at home.
It's like the game Password,
but your partner
is a smart speaker, okay?
Now, first, I will pick a card
with a word on it,
then we'll take turns asking
a question to get the speaker
to say that word
somewhere in its answer.
If it does, you get a point.
-Can I just tell them?
I've never spoken
to one of these before,
so I don't know how they work
and...forgive.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, yeah.
You have to say --
-Yeah, yeah.
-This one's Alexa.
I'll go first.
I'll show you.
Yeah, here we go. Ready?
[ Beep ]
Okay.
Oh, this is the word.
Yeah, okay.
Alexa, what is the story
"Three Little Kittens"?
-This might answer
your question.
Here is a summary
of "Three Little Kittens" --
"This story is
about the misadventures
of three little kittens,
how their mother
disciplines them,
and how they try to do better."
[ Laughter ]
-No!
[ Buzzer ]
What?!
[ Sad trombone, rimshot ]
That's not what it's about.
They lost their mittens!
What are you talking about?
Their mother disciplines them?
Are you out of your mind?!
-Oh, my God.
-That's real?
-She gives a spiritual analysis
of the book.
-What?!
-Oh, my goodness.
-Alright, alright.
Now, you have to say,
"Hey," blank,
and get her to say this word.
-Okay.
I have to get her to say this?
-Yeah.
-Okay.
-Mitten.
-Okay. Okay.
Alexa,
what is a glove
with no fingers?
[ Laughter ]
-According to an Alexa Answers
contributor,
fingerless gloves.
Did that answer your question?
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
[ Sad trombone, rimshot ]
-She was right!
-She burned you so hard.
-She's right!
She burned you pretty hard.
-You were right!
[ Laughs ]
That's a burn right there, oh!
-She's so much smarter than me.
The algorithms are taking over
and they deserve it.
-They deserve it.
-They deserve what they get.
-Alright, we're passing.
Let's go to the next word.
-Okay, wow.
-Here we go.
Alright, I have to say...
-You.
-I have to have them somehow
say this.
Alright, ready?
Do you want to do this?
-I think I know how to get her.
-Why don't you do it?
-Okay. Okay.
What is the show on NBC --
-You have to say the name.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Alexa, Alexa,
what is an NBC show
with Katharine McPhee?
-Here's something
I found on the Web.
According to decider.com,
from 2012 to 2013,
McPhee's career as an actress
soared to new heights
with her star turn
as Karen Cartwright
in NBC musical drama series
"Smash."
-Yes! Come on, now!
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
It's rewarding.
It feels good, right?
-It's good. [ Laughs ]
-It feels good.
Feels good.
You nailed it! You nailed it!
You knew it.
I was going to say,
"Who sang 'All Star'?
'Hey, now, you're an all star.'"
Alright, I have to get her --
-Oh, that's good.
That one's better.
-Ooh!
-Would've gotten there quicker.
-I have to get her to say this.
-Oh, my goodness.
[ Audience ohs ]
-Oh, no. Oh, no.
-Hm, this is interesting. Here.
[ Laughter ]
Alexa, what is iPhone's
virtual assistant's name?
-Here's something
I found on the Web.
According to ukessays.com,
in 2011, Apple launched Siri
on its iPhone --
[ Bell dinging ]
There you go, right there.
[ Rimshot ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
Still got it. Still got it.
-Whoo!
Whoo! Whoo!
-I still got it.
Alright, Alexa stop, please.
Stop talking.
[ Laughter ]
Alright, Kate,
this is your last one.
This one's worth 1,000 points.
-Oh, my goodness.
Okay.
-Alright. Shamrock.
-Shamrock.
-Okay.
Yes.
Alexa, what is another word
for four-leafed clover?
-Here's something I found
on the Web.
-Please.
-According to fica.com,
quadrifoglio is named
after the Italian word
for four-leaf clover --
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Perfect.
[ Buzzer ]
[ Sad trombone, rimshot ]
Quadrifoglio. You don't know?
You're not familiar
with quadrifoglio?
Fantastic. Alright, let me try.
Let me try.
-Alexa, what milkshake
does McDonald's make
every St. Patrick's Day?
-Hm, I don't know that one.
[ Aws, cheering, and applause ]
-Sure you do!
[ Sad trombone, rimshot ]
You know quadrifonia,
you don't know --
Boy. Alright,
how how am I going to get this?
-Okay, okay.
Alexa, what's like
[ Laughter ]
a green
symbol on an
-This might answer
your question.
-Irish pub grill?
According to Wikipedia...
-Please!
-...green is the color
between cyan and yellow
on the visible spectrum --
[ Buzzer ]
[ Sad trombone, rimshot ]
-Alright. We know what green is!
We know what green is!
Alexa, stop it!
-[Indistinct]
-Alexa, stop.
Stop!
What are you saying, 78? Gosh!
[ Laughter ]
Alexa,
what is a symbol
of Irish people?
[ Laughter ]
-Here's something
I found on the Web.
According to wikitechy.com,
shamrock.
[ Bell dinging ]
[ Rimshot ]
[ Laughs ]
-Ohhh, God, yes!
Yes! Yes! Yes!
-That's what I'm talking about!
That was great, right?!
-Yes!
-Come on.
Kate McKinnon, everybody.
-Whoo!
-[ Laughs ]
"Joe vs Carole" premieres
-Wow.
-this Thursday on Peacock.